[Música]
entre los siguientes lugares para vivir
cuáles poner y a un lugar donde todo
estar los vientos fuertes humanos todo a
pasto un lugar donde hay una gota de
agua dulce de cerca y un lugar donde
vivimos durante seis meses al año
pues te cuento algo mi familia mi
comunidad mis gallinas y yo tenemos
todos esos ambientes ninguno nos ha
tocado aprender a adaptarnos a ser
sobrevivientes a ser residentes en esta
especie de
cambio climático que vivimos especial
para algunos solamente es la sequía
durante seis meses pero no se deshaga la
tierra no sólo si se nos daba la tierra
todo lo que está sembrado en ella de
hortalizas de paso se pierde a nosotros
que nos toca vivir seis meses en el agua
en la orilla de la carretera porque las
casas se nos harán a parcelas se nos
harán mueren
nos vamos a plantarnos y no tenemos agua
dulce acerca la más cercana está a 5
kilómetros de distancia
oa pie uno más cercano en bicicleta
y otro en nuestro lugar de jugada pta 2
y hemos prosperado para llevar el agua a
nuestra casa ya nuestras gallinas que
son las únicas que no nos acompañan acá
no hay ser vos acá no hay ganado porque
tener eso es tener más complicaciones
tenemos solamente gallinas que se
adaptan al igual que nosotros las
anterioridad a los cambios climáticos
nosotros estamos ubicados en la vereda
san francisco de cítara perteneciente al
municipio de san bernardo del tiempo
cerca del río sin un departamento de
córdoba colombia
vivimos en este lugar citó que era un
paraíso que era una tierra que todo lo
que le sembraron esperabas sin haber ahí
hacer mayor esfuerzo
nuevamente sembrados preparados con la
tierra esperábamos las lluvias y
solamente a cerrar y a reportear ya
recomendar todavía en plagas no había
limitaciones que nos atormentan
todo era
excelente salían a pescar y conseguían
afectados sin mayor en puerto solamente
con un anzuelo con una flecha o con una
tapa ya teníamos todo lo que
necesitábamos en el papel teníamos la
pequeña que no se nos perdían las
gallinas no nos dábamos cuenta cabo de
tres semanas parecían con viento se
publicó
próspera van solas solamente solitas
cuando llegaban a la casa pierde el
tirón porque mirábamos en la zona
céntrica a comer la cabecita del arroz y
así nos llenábamos teníamos 10 12 20
hasta tiempo tipo esa era nuestra
comunidad sembrábamos yuca plátano
ambos eran nuestra producción el arroz
será la base sustentable de los hogares
o el arroz se encontraban las
necesidades que tuvieran las necesidades
que no teníamos ciertas por lo ha
contestado y guardábamos arroz para todo
el año y aguantamos la función de a
nuevas para alimentar a nuestra calle
que siempre ha estado ahí en las buenas
el hombre inteligente por todo
el río de los cauces comenzaron nuestros
problemas ya nuestros ríos y [ __ ] que
es una fuente del río xingú comenzó a
sedimentarse de vida
al corte del río grande del cambio
firmado climático en este momento
desconocíamos con eso hacer sus estragos
más en nuestra vida ya las lluvias se
hacía menos frecuente
sergio se fue secando al estar tan cerca
del marco sectario intenta decir mucho
en las aguas saladas penetraron por las
ciénegas que entró vean nuestra vereda
comenzaron a instalarse y de paso
instalaron nuestras fuentes de agua
instalaron nuestra tierra todo lo que
allí había exterminio solamente nos
quedaba la sal en los patios y nuestras
gallinas que fácilmente se adaptaban y
aprendieron a sobrevivir un poca agua
definitivamente éramos pero una
catástrofe para nosotros no sabíamos
cómo podríamos sobrellevar estas cosas
muchas familias emigraron a otros
lugares buscando un mejor futuro pero
ningunas familias que fuimos residente
que fuimos vacas que tuvo suerte y nos
quedamos en este lugar
a esperar a ver qué pasaba esperando la
oportunidad de que ese día porque
pensábamos que los tiempos bombers
volverían a ser intelectuales porque
volvieron la lluvia
qué tragedia nos anega nunca nos
habíamos animado de nuestro pasado yo
era una niña cuando llegué a esta tierra
y esto era invierno y verano que eran
unas bendiciones porque tenían todos los
estaciones nos esperábamos para en cada
estación cuidaba su época de cosecha ya
no teníamos invierno solamente
inundaciones ya no teníamos verano
solamente agua salada y sequía por todos
lados más sin embargo nosotros nos
adaptamos y tuvimos nuestra propia
página y con ella aprendimos a vivir ya
sobrevivir y enfrentaron a todas las
adversidades
pereda está conformada por indios e
indios
negros y mestizos que hacen clases y han
hecho una fuente
la fuerte raza una corte grasa que
sobrevive a la propiedad de que no le
pedimos a lo que tenemos que no notamos
con festivos hampa también hemos logrado
obtener nuestras propias herramientas
que hemos logrado idear nuestros propios
planes para llevar nuestra vida adelante
hacemos piscinas y nuestra tierra para
sacar tierra de ahí y echarle a nuestra
casa para no a negarnos en la próxima
estación no tenemos que salir a hacer
esta noche a la vida a la carretera y
caser aterrado para nuestras gallinas
hacemos campo elevado antes de la del
agua para mantener a nuestras gallinas
en unos grandes especiales el momento
más difícil sabemos que no tenemos otra
opción sino echarle mano de las gallinas
llegó a la visita tenemos la gallina
para estas ocho senos enfermos para un
fácil pariente el sancocho al consumir
para la enfermedad que tenemos necesidad
de vendas venga las gallinas comerciales
consiga lo que hace
sabemos que no podemos esperar y hay una
vez más que tenemos que valernos por
nosotros mismos y los únicos que podemos
sembrar la época buena porque llega la
actividad no hay limitaciones ni hay
tantos días aprovechamos al máximo para
prosperar nuestras gallinas porque
sabemos que al final de este tiempo va a
venir una fuerte sequía o una fuerte
inundación ya nosotros necesitamos una
fuente de cada día que son disponibles
solamente las féminas acá no se va a
hacer lo haga no se da el ganado porque
nuestras tierras no son aptas para sus
cultivos
nuestra gente ha ideado una especie de
gallinas usadas para la gallina
comercial la gallina que hoy hemos
logrado y una nueva raza de gallinas que
la llamamos preguntó un experto que son
resistentes a las enfermedades por los
rayos y hoy lo que tenemos que a
castillo unos buenos ponedoras una vez
pequeña que no requieren de mucha agua
que se han adaptado muy bien a nuestras
calamidades que estamos en verano
también se están en invierno también a
finales del año que comenzamos a sacar
poquito en toda la sequía y yo crecen en
la tierra ensalada con poco pasto por
unas obras de nuestra parte la yuca
de la verdura todo lo que le podemos
echar ellos 31 meses en esas tierras
llegan la de invierno ya ella están
listas para poner a veces otros
encerradas en cantones para que pongan
allá porque ya no tienen tierra donde
correr porque ya todo es auto esa es
nuestra vida esas son nuestras gallinas
esas son nuestras compañeras se vuelven
imprescindible en todo momento llegó al
cumpleaños de uno de nuestros hijos o
vamos a celebrar los 80 o se engañó a
uno de nuestros abuelos vamos a hacerle
un arroz de pollo pero no pueblo
comerciando con gallinas que no tienen
comparación porque porque siempre todos
los provee lo que nosotros necesitamos
nuestras gallinas no lo conectan con
gallinas que se han adaptado fácilmente
las enseñamos a darles agua
pongamos para desparasitar las a darle
agua con un zumo de limón las cáscaras
de limón para contarle las emociones
pero le echamos por humo
este alimento idea simbiótico para las
enfermedades y ellas fácilmente nuestro
poder y siguen adelante
al igual que nosotros cambiamos el gallo
cada dos años porque ya es mayoría en un
pool y nuevamente tenemos la misma silla
de la vamos modificando
vemos que podemos mejorar creemos que
podemos salir adelante sabemos que
tendremos que luchar más y más que
seguiremos dándole a la pelea a la sal
tenemos dándole la pelea a las
inundaciones y a la adversidad en el
cambio climático y a la desidia de los
gobernantes de turno
los otros son un pueblo que ha logrado
prosperar en medio de todo eso al unir
nuestras razas negras y viera y
efectivas la mezcla que ha salido de
aquí es una mezcla resistente echao
p'alante de razas que no se amilana ante
las adversidades que sabemos que si
sembramos la cosecha y nos va amargo que
se hundió pues contamos con un propósito
que podemos salvar y sabemos que tenemos
una fuente de ingresos y de comida en
medio de todo con las gallinas en cada
patio de nuestros hogares hay gallinas
dañinas por montones que son las que
siempre van a estar ahí en todos los
momentos de nuestra vida
nosotros esperamos que todo esto cambie
las aguas ya no nos puedan inundar que
realmente tengan el río pues el tallo
cuya normalmente que nuestras tierras no
se salen que tengamos la misma
oportunidad de cosechar
este tema
y meter la olla donde está tu propia
pesca
pescaditos pequeños que muchas veces
tienen de proteína para la pequeña
esperamos volver a tener todo eso pero
sabemos que eso es un trabajo que
tenemos que lograr y que aunque vuelvan
estos tiempos nuestros aún más
inclinados a tenerte a llenas que a
tener otra clase de de animales porque
ella nos encanta porque éste recuerda
nuestras amigas revuelven nuestras
compañeras de hierbas porque nuestras
presidente y cuatro mejores
creemos que si las gallinas nosotros no
son el pueblo
porque los demás es más difícil tenerlo
en todas las adversidades que teniendo
solamente creemos
que ella encontrará más dañinas con
mucho solamente
que eso es todo lo que tenía que
contarle de mi prueba de las residencias
que teníamos de la verdad que era que
tenemos
muchas razas
pues los humanos en la página los mismos
residentes son los mismos batalladores
no producimos expertos en sobrevivir
ante las palabras gracias